what is so will come
photography is like a flash of euphoria
and gave me a voice
once I started sharing the work it was
really heavy resistance
especially from male artists and
gallerists who said this is in
photography
nobody photographs their own life
it's a photographer named golden she's a
major name in the art world the work was
incredibly political
probably my whole life
struggle to fight Conformity and denial
[Music]
there's the Sackler family of the art
world the museum world and philanthropy
and then there's the big Pharma
marketing and addiction and death
my anger at the cycler family it's
personal when you think of the profit of
people's pain
you can only be furious
[Music]
I said I think I think take these people
down
but do you think my career will implode
and I said probably we need to demand
that the Met Museum to lose the tape
refuse donations from the sacklers and
take down their names
[Music]
the rich people are scared that we're
going to dig into the evil way they make
money
you grow up being told
that didn't happen you didn't see that
how do you trust yourself and so that's
the reason I take pictures
it's a watershed moment people are
actually beginning to rethink how we do
things
are kept secret in society
and that destroys people
[Music]